ﾊﾔｸ!ﾊﾔｸｲｺ!!! ﾈｪ!!!
待て待て…
ﾊﾔｸ!!! ﾊﾔｸ!!!
ﾈｪ!!ﾈｴ!! ﾊﾔｸ!!!
ｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀ
ﾈｪ､ﾊﾔｸｯｳｩ... (ｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀ)
待て待て待ってｗ
アンノーン、アンノーン8匹らしいっす
アンノーン？
バリヤード
バリヤード？
行こうぜ(笑)
ﾓｳ、ｶﾞﾏﾝﾃﾞｷﾅｲｨﾖｫｫ!
(はじめのあくび)
では、赤レンガ倉庫に向かいます。
はい、もう近くまで来たんですけどもぉ
あの～、もう近くがすごいです
はい、ミルタンクいるよ。
それ捕まえた方がいい？
これはねぇ、なかなかレアだと思う
ｱｯﾋｯﾋｯﾋｯﾋｯﾋ
やばい、やばい
メリープメリープ
メリープゥ！？
やばい、マジやばいやばいどうなってんの
あ、なに、ヨーギラスいる！
ヨーギラスいる！ヨーギラスいる！
どうなってんの？！
え、ガチでやばくない？
来たしょこれ
あっ・・・（笑）
あっ・・・
みんなポケモンGOやってんじゃん
ほらー みんなスマホ触ってるよ
うわ時代だなー
もうすぐ着きますかね
(運転手)ここが赤レンガ付近。
ありがとうございます
おぉ～これかー
人すごいね
すげーじゃんみんなGOしてるじゃん
うわすげーな
え、やば、みんな みんなポケモンGOしてる
アンノーンアンノーンアンノーン！
おー急げ急げ
人が怖いなぁ
まって、同じじゃん同じじゃん
つかまえたつかまえた
かわりますよ
え、え、待って
ねぇ待って待って待って
入んなくなったんだけど
ちょっとちょっとちょっと
ワイもワイも
うそうそ
なんかめっちゃ周りの人が落ちてるみたいですみんな
なんかそっちでも聞こえたもんね
docomo ?docomoが終わってんのかな
あーオレdocomoっす
とりあえずコンビニ行こう
えーちょっと現状を話させていただきますとぉ
なんか多分アクセスが集中しすぎてて
GPSが動かなくなっています
なんでなんでなんで！
なんでできんの？
ジャイロボール
逃げろ！頑張れ！あー！
くそー！
1回ちょっとあっち行きましょう
(視聴者)頑張ってください！
はい！ありがとうごうざいます！
パーク内はだめなんですけど
周りはいけるみたいです
入れないでしょ？
入れない
どうするこれ？
あ、待って待ってインターネットに繋がらないよ
なんで！？
なにが起きてるんだ！！(おこ)
ちょっと1回離れてもらって
ぐるっと1周して多分電波がいま集中してて
繋がらないんで
ぐるっと1周してもう1回来ます
ｲﾔﾎﾝﾄﾆﾓｳ!
ﾏｯﾃｪｪｪ!!!
ﾓｳﾔﾀﾞﾔﾀﾞﾔﾀﾞ!!
えーー
せっかくヨーロッパの旅費を浮かせうとしたのに
だいちくんがテザリングすればいいんじゃない？
あ来た来た来た
あ、テザリング作戦ありだね
だいちくんのできないマン？
あれだわ、確かauテザリングオプションで別契約だ
あーなるほどね
いやこれ出た瞬間にハジメンGOじゃない？
いやもうハジメンGOされてもいいやもう
いい？
オレもうバリヤードとアンノーンを捕まえることだけに今日は
専念する
よし…
復帰できました！
おぉ！
ただどうするこのあと
また行ってさ同じようなことになると怖いよね
とりあえずもう落とさないようにしていこう
落とすと多分もう戻れないから
もう1回ちょっとパークの近くまで行ってみます
では！
えぇー捕まえれなかったらオレ
今日マジ何してんだよってはなしになるよぉー
さすがに捕まえられますよ
オレは…
バリヤードを諦めかけていた…
もう時間がない…！
オレはそう思って、最終兵器を使った…
…そう！
2人乗り自転車だ
2人乗り自転車に乗っていれば歩きスマホをせず
歩くよりも速いペースでタマゴの孵化の距離を稼げる
そう！
オレはすなわち
勝ち組だ！
赤レンガのポケストップ付近でとれる2kmタマゴからは
レアなポケモンが生まれる
(子供A)はじめしゃちょー！
(子供B)はじめしゃちょー！
(子供C)はじめしゃちょー！
めっちゃバレる めっちゃめっちゃ…
めっちゃバレる めっちゃバレる…
みんな、バリヤード頑張ってね！
(子供たち)もう捕まえました！
もう捕まえたの！？
(子供D)ルギアゲットした！
ルギアゲットしたの！？
だが残念ながら
自転車に乗っている間は
バリヤードに出会えなかった…
いやぁ、ちょっとないかなぁ
やっぱり中入んないとだめなのかな
はい、というわけで赤レンガ倉庫付近に
行ってきたんですけども
バリヤード…！
捕まえれました…
(はじめの泣き声)
とりあえずバリヤードはほんとヨーロッパでしか出ないんで
ほんとにみなさん捕まえれる方は
捕まえといたほうがいいです！
ヨーロッパの旅費が浮きますからね
んで、ちょっと今から行く人に
ちょっと注意事項なんですけども
ほんとにネット環境が悪いです
一応ポケモンパーク内は撮影禁止なので
捕まえる瞬間だけスクショしてきました
あーまずこれ2kmタマゴ
うん、もう、あーやべ、もうほら、あの
ポリゴンが出たんですけども、もう重すぎて
バグでポリゴンが表示されないっていう
とりあえず何もかもが重かった、この会場は
もうひょっとしたら
アプリが起動できるかどうかのレベルだと思います
ポケストップを回しても反応がありません
重すぎて
で、ほら見て、もうこれさ、見える？
もう、バリヤードがいるんですよ
でアンノーンもいるんですよ！ほら！
アンノーン アンノーン
アンノーンもバリヤードもいて
僕、頑張ってこれ押そうとしてるんですけども
タッチがまったく反応しません
バリヤードがずっと
このポケストップをペタペタ触っているだけっていう
この状況が約5分続きました
おーエラーが出ました
めっちゃ、めっちゃタッチしてるの分かります？バリヤード
もう結果的に粘りに粘ってタッチしまくったら
ようやくバリヤードに触れて
無事、戦闘？
捕まえるシーンまで入れたんですけども
ほんっっとにキツいですよ
僕がdocomoだったからかもしれないですけども
ほんとに回線がひどくて
はい、というわけで
ヨーロッパ限定のポケモンが日本で捕まえることができました！
で、アンノーンも無事
なんとか捕まえることができましたので
一応今回のこの赤レンガの
お目当てのポケモンは無事ゲットすることができました！
あの、ほんとに回線がすっげえ混んでるんで
ポケットWi-Fiとかを持ってほうがいいのかな
とりあえず僕は普通にスマホだけ持っていくと
めちゃくちゃつらい思いをしたというお話でございます
バリヤードを捕まえる時には皆さんお気をつけて！
じゃあな！